más de 48 millones de franceses están
llamados a las urnas para elegir a sus
diputados francia está dividida en 577
circunscripciones para quinientos
setenta y siete diputados que formarán
parte de la asamblea nacional un
candidato puede ser elegido en la
primera vuelta se obtiene más del 50% de
los votos siempre y cuando participe al
menos el 25 por ciento de los votantes
registrados en caso contrario se
organiza una segunda vuelta con los dos
primeros candidatos y con los aspirantes
que hayan obtenido al menos el 12 5% de
los sufragios registrados en esta
votación la abstención podría superar el
50 por ciento en ese caso sería
necesario obtener al menos el 25 por
ciento de los votos emitidos para poder
optar a la candidatura
la mayoría de los 70.000 colegios
electorales de francia cerraran a las 6
de la tarde -hora local- excepto en
algunas grandes ciudades donde cerrarán
a las 7 o incluso a las 8 de la noche